Hãy xa hồng gân ngày bắt mọi thứ mỗi trở biết đơn vị điều tra thương vòng đáng
hoàn tất vực xanh nhận an toàn cho một chăm năm mi chính cự dân
tình đồ báo cá mất tích xa vụ hả ngoại lớn xảy ra tầm khu dân cơ hôm 20 xa
trong mi một thông tin này được công bố tại của họ báo, zao, trang, xuất in,
sẽ quan phổ chắc đơn vị điều tra thương vòng chủ trì
theo cầm nhận đến người xa ông xa cùng ngày dụ nguy tử vòng đã tăng lên một chăm mỗi mi xa
chân hợp trong khi có bài mi chính người bị thương, tế tục lượng điều chỉ tại các cơ xa
báo tích thương vòng, tế tế tế, dời chức cũng cho biết quá chính giác mành gặp nhiều khó khăn
zao dữ liệu bắt đầu thiếu thông nhất, một số người được báo cá mất tích thương cơ chủ
tại khu nhà bị tránh, mọc thông tin được công gấp không đầy đủ, hiện có một chăm
trường hợp được phân rọi là không thể truy tình, chủ yếu là gió thiếu thông tin
liên hệ hoặc không xa định được nơi ở cuộc thay.
Chính quyền cho biết cộng tất điều tra môi nhân vụ hả ngoạn và đối chức thông tin dân cơ
sẽ tích tục được chình khai, nhằm hoàn thiện hồn sơ và hỗ trợ cơ ra định của liên quan.